she came up with this rule okay what's
that I can't work with any female
artists
and she won't work with any email
well it was right she came up with this
rule did you come up with this rule
after the fact that something that
happened
it's not the best rule it's a terrible
rule because now it's down now
it works
he want the same thing so what you even
talking to them for if you came up with
this weird-ass rule
I said
you were we was before that weekend he
didn't take me to the session he didn't
take me to the video shoot none of that
he was being weird so he's being weird
with the feature it made me like
what that's that's what what happened we
was